[Musique]
yannck jado bonjour bonjour nous vous
recevons pour une chaîne Youtube qui
s'appelle serw on vous reçoit dans le
cadre de la présidentielle de
2017 pourquoi vous présente
parce que je pense qu'il y a pas de
fatalité à ce que ce pays sombre dans la
névrose qu' a des forces des énergies
vitales incroyables dans la société dans
les associations dans les entreprises
dans les même dans les institutions dans
les centres de recherche et qu'ils sont
en train de construire aujourd'hui le
monde de demain mais que toutes ces
personnes toutes ces énergies toutes ces
initiatives elles sont aujourd'hui en
marge des politiques publiques moi je
veux les mettre au cœur des politiques
publiques il y a encore 2 jours j'étais
avec toute la société civile pour
commémorer le 10e anniversaire de la
mort de l'abbé Pierre et que ce soit
dans le champ social dans le champ de la
solidarité dans le champ de
l'environnement c'est incroyable de voir
à quel point on a les solutions pour une
société qui irait bien et
malheureusement et ben quelles sont vos
solutions pour réguler les banques
d'affaires et les banques de détail
alors un il faut les séparer il vous a
pas échappé que la séparation des banes
banque d'affaires les banques de dépôts
n'avait pas été jusqu'au bout parce que
finalement les banques dans nos pays
aujourd'hui occupe une place qui est
incroyablement plus importante que
n'importe quel secteur d'activité les
banques réuni les principal Blanque ont
un une activité financière bancaire qui
est plus importante que notre produit
intérieur brut donc il faut pas
simplement quel est notre produit
intérieur brut on est à 1 300 2400 mais
il faut pas simplement milliards
milliards bien sûr il faut pas
simplement séparer pour limiter
l'engagement de l'État à sauver les
banques quand elles font des affaires
qu'elles prennent énormément de risque
parce qu'on doit en même temps sauver
les banques de dépôts et donc le dépôt
des épargnants mais il faut agir pour
réduire la taille des banques
aujourd'hui elles ont une taille qui est
beaucoup trop importante et un des
enjeux comme vous savez en France on a
mis en place une taxe bancaire cette
taxe bancaire qui est une sorte de taxe
sur les transactions financières
finalement qui joue sur le bilan des
banques sur les notamment sur le ratio
prudentiel c'est important et elle doit
disparaître en 2019 et ben il faut faire
tout l'inverse il faut pas simplement
qu'elle subsiste mais il faut qu'elle
soit accrue il faut absolument limiter
la taille des qu'est-ce que vous pouvez
me dire du FESF et du
MES alors euh le euh mécanisme
européen de solidarité et qui a été mis
en place notamment après la crise 1 des
dettes privées puis transformé en dte
publ est un mécanisme de solidarité
européen c'est privé c'est public c'est
quoi c'est basé où ah bah écoutez le
mécanisme il est basé au niveau européen
qu'est-ce qui fait l'appel à la
cotisation c'est les les les États qui
se retrouvent en difficulté font appel
au mécanisme européens de solidarité le
problème de ce mécanisme qui dans l'idée
de la solidarité est plutôt une bonne
idée ça a notamment permis quand même
d'aérer de donner un peu d'oxygène à des
pays comme la Grèce ou à d'autres qui
étaient en difficulté le problèmeation
ça ça a pas aéré ça a pas aéré la Grèce
ça a permis de sauver la Société
Générale et laissez-moi laissez-moi y
venir l'idée d'un mécanisme de
solidarité elle est bonne le problème
c'est que toutes les premières tranches
de solidarité ont effectiv sauver les
banques françaises et allemandes qui
s'étaient engagé en toute connaissance
de cause en prenant des risques
extraordinaire en jouant de la
falsification des comptes grecs et elles
ont été les premières à être sauvées
mais qu ça c'est Goldman sax qui a fait
ça non pire que ça bah Goldman sach
était était effectivement intervenant
dans l'évaluation de la stabilité de
l'économie grecque et de ses comptes
mais le pire dans tout ça c'est que pour
déclencher
des fonds il faut que le gouvernement
qui demande des fonds aille en
négociation avec l'Eurogroup et ça a
donné le pire du sadisme qu'on peut
faire en matière de gouvernance
économique à l'échelle européenne ça a
été les fameuses troica c'est
leurogroupe qui y a pas encore longtemps
osé dire un truc aussi farfelu que la
décision du gouvernement grec d'allouer
une prime de Noël au retraités les plus
en difficulté était totalement avec
l'Eurogroupe et que l'Eurogroupe reculer
le le la révision ou l'allègement des
dettes donc il faut absolument changer
toute la gouvernance économique de
l'Eurogroupe à la fois sur la
l'orientation politique mais ça
malheureusement il faut gagner des
élections mais avec un parlement de la
zone euro le pire de l'Eurogroup c'est
qu'il n'est comptable devant aucune
institution démocratique ils peuvent
faire n'importe quoi ils n'ont de compte
à rendre à personne comm c'est ça qui
est basé au Luxembourg il faut
absolument que il y a un parlement de la
zone euro qui contrôle ce qui est fait
et qui fasse surtout qu'on recrée de la
solidarité en Europe et pas de
l'humiliation politique qui conduit à
des désastres sociaux et démocratiques
et une de mes propositions c'est qu'on
ait un plan d'investissement de 600
milliards d'euros par an vous les
trouver où la Banque centrale européenne
aujourd'hui elle sort 80 milliards
d'euros par mois pour acheter sur le
marché secondaire de la dette publique
on sait que ça alimente des bulles
spéculatives financières bancaires que
ça ça ne ça ne ça ne permet pas
d'investir sur l'économie réale moi cet
argent là plutôt moins puisque je suis à
600 milliards d'euros par an il doit
aller pour garantir ou racheter des
prêts de la Banque européenne
d'investissement qui aille sur la
transition énergétique économie
d'énergie énergie renouvelable c'est pas
simplement des millions d'emplois à
l'échelle européenne c'est
l'indépendance vis-àis des régimes
dictatoriaux de Poutine des
pétromonarchies du golf et d'ailleurs le
régime de Poutine c'est un régime
dictatorial ah bah je crois que quand
les les les journalistes qui enquêtent
sont tués quand les opposants qui osent
s'opposer sont tués quand on massacre et
qu'on a détruit y compris culturellement
la téie quand on annexe la Crimée qu'on
fait la guerre en Donbass et quand on
massacre les populations à Halep je
crois que ça s'appelle une dictature
donc donc c'est alors est-ce que la
France qui vend des armes à l'Arabie
Saoudite qui l'Arabie Saoudite bombarde
au Yémen est-ce que la France est une
dictature ah non la France et de dans
cette dans ce cas-là d'une abominable
complaisance vis-à-vis des
pétromonarchies du golf que je dénonçais
juste avant qui non seulement comme vous
le dites font une guerre abominable au
yen mais exporte une vision fascisante
de la religion et tant qu'on aura pas
réduit supprimé notre addiction au
pétrole et donc notre complaisance
vis-à-vis de ces régimes là à la fois
parce qu'on leur achète leur pétrole et
qu'on leur vend nos armes nous n'aurons
jamais de diplomatie qui mettent les
droits humains les droits sociaux les
droits environnementaux en privilège
quel est le budget militaire du
ministère de la Défense saoudien j'en
sais absolument rien0 milliard on ce que
je crois c'est que dans cette région du
Moyen-Orient il a sur les 10 dernières
années il a été dépensé un trillions
c'est-à-dire 1000 milliards de dollars
en achat d'armes c'est 10 % de
l'ensemble des PIB de la région alors
que dans beaucoup de ces pays les
enfants n'ont pas forcément accès à
l'éducation l'investissement dans
l'armement de la Russie c'est combien je
pas j'en sais rien j'aurais pas un
chiffre comme ça c'est 60 milliards bah
c'est beaucoup c'est toute façon c'est
c'est c'est beaucoup surtout que ça sert
une vision expansionniste est-ce que
vous pensez que la Russie est un état
expansionniste ah bah quand vous
commencez à annexer des pays
contrairement à toutes les lois
internationales comme la Crimée ça
s'appelle de l'expansionnisme quand vous
êtes intervenu en geéorgie et que dans
les régions où vous avez pris la main il
y a une forme de dépuration ethnique au
sens où les ceux qui refusent le
passeport russe sont sont sorti de la
région et ben ça s'appelle de
l'expansionnisme est-ce que Mayot
c'était de l'expansionniste
l'expansionisme
français ce qui est certain c'est que
une bonne partie des territoires
ultramarins ont toujours relevé d'une
forme de
colonialisme au-delà
évidemment des frontières et reste des
partis au fond il y a eu un référendum à
Mayotte non il y a eu un référendum à
Mayotte mais c'est surtout euh de savoir
euh le le le Mayotte a envie de rester
parce qu'il voit aussi la situation au
Comor qui est dramatique la situation
sociale comment ce qui est tout le
problème c'est comment on arrive à
recréer de l'autonomie de nos
territoires ultraamarins pour qu'ils
sortent parfois d'une relation qui est
une relation de néocolonialisme il faut
de l'autonomie est-ce que vous pensez
que l'OTAN a des visions expansionnistes
aujourd'hui l'OTAN ça n'existe plus
regardez avec l'arrivée de Trump l'UTAN
voilà Trump veut presque se désengager
de l'OTAN la situation avec Erdogan qui
est un pays normalement enfin la Turquie
est un pays important de l'OTAN
aujourd'hui l'OTAN au fond est une
largement une coquie vide ce qu'il faut
en revanche et moi j'en suis partisan
c'est une politique européenne de
défense parce que sans politique
européenne de défense nous n'aurons pas
de politique étr étrangère sérieuse que
la plupart des régions autour de
l'Europe aujourd'hui sont profondément
déstabilisées pour parti c'est notre
responsabilité pour parti ce sont
d'autres responsabilités et donc
maintenant qu'avec Trump on a acté que
le parapluie américain sétait refermé il
y aurait plus de parapluie américain sur
l'Europe il faut qu'on sache se prendre
en main les bataillons de char de
l'utant qu'on a vu passer jusqu'en
Pologne les les les chars anglais qui
passent sous le tunnel dans la Manche en
ce moment qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
je pense que de toute façon encore une
fois il faut moi je suis pour la une
politique européenne de défense y
compris pour réduire les budgets on a à
peu près 2 millions de soldats à
l'échelle européenne on en a pas pas
autour de 70000 qui sont capables de se
projeter sur des terrains ou
d'intervention donc on a à la fois à
gagner beaucoup d'argent en économie
probablement à à commencé à créer des
vrais corps d'intervention de paix mais
on a de toute façon intérêt à avoir une
une armée européenne Obama il méritait
son prixobel de la paix j'ai pas entendu
pardon est-ce que Obama méritait son
prix Nobel de la Paix euh c'est le
problème de du du prix Nobel de la Paix
d'Obama c'est qu'il a été donné en
anticipation
euh des actes qu'il pourrait poser et
non pas en récompense des actes qu'il a
posé il a reçu le prix Nobel
singulièrement pour deux choses un euh
lutter contre le dérèglement climatique
il a finalement peu fait y compris parce
qu' au bout d'un moment il avait pu le
Congrès avec lui ça a été difficile mais
au départ il avait clairement arbitraer
l'obamacer plutôt que la lutte contre le
dérèglement climatique et puis il devait
aussi être un des vecteur de la paix
notamment entre Israël et Palestine et
que ça c'est quand même un terrain qu' a
délaissé jusqu'à il y a un mois et c'est
évidemment aujourd'hui trop tard
malheureusement pour que les États-Unis
soient un acteur de paix et euh dans
dans la région et contraigne Israël à
arrêter notamment les phases de
colonisation la NSA c'était un acte de
paix c'était quoi les écoutes de la NSA
ah c'est un scandale absolu mais c'est
un scandale qui malheureusement s'est
fait le plus souvent avec la complicité
de service de renseignement européen on
l'a vu la NSA s'est révélé en avril mai
juin 2013 notamment avec Snowden on est
en même temps avec l'ouverture de
négociation d'un grand partenariat
transatlantique prétendument grand
partenariat transatlantique Europe
États-Unis le tafta et même à ce
moment-là alors qu'il était avéré que la
NSA non seulement espionnit des millions
de citoyens européens espionn nos
institutions européennes espionn nos
gouvernements il n'y a même pas eu de
mesures de rétorsion pour dire nous ne
pouvons pas en confiance négocier un
traité de libre échange alors que nous
sommes espionnés ce qui est abominable
dans l'histoire c'est que on a vu que et
les services de renseignement
britannique ont toujours été au fond des
complices de cet espionnage de la NSA on
a vu les services de renseignement
allemand participai à l'espionnage de la
France et on se dit qu'au moment
notamment dans un moment incroyable de
tension et de risque terroriste au
moment où il devrai accroître
profondément leur coopération pour
lutter contre le terrorisme et ben
finalement il nous espionne pour des
intérêts commerciaux ou politiques qui
sont nos et à bon est-ce que les les
États-Unis sont une dictature de basse
intensité non je dirais pas que les
intensité oui je sais pas ce que ça veut
dire la démocratie il y a pas une seule
démocratie qui soit complète et
satisfaisante ça c'est une évidence que
quand les
États-Unis envahissent l'IRAC et
déstabilise profondément et encore pour
des probablement des décennies toute la
région parce que au fond c'est l'accès
au pétrole c'est abominable c'est un
exercice profond de déstabilisation mais
quand je suis américain et que je veux
manifester contre l'arrivée de Trump au
pouvoir je peux aller dans la rue sans
me faire arrêter parce que je manifeste
contre Trump il y a aussi la liberté de
la presse il y a aussi des
contrepouvoirs il y a Guantanamo il y a
la NSA il y a le patriote Act il y a des
guerres impérialistes de dire euh que
les États-Unis sont une dictature même
de basse intensité je suis pas d'accord
c'est-à-dire que si vous êtes fiché
parce que vous allez rester plus de 1
heure avec des hackurs là que votre
téléphone portable est avec nous pendant
1 heure ça vous dérange pas d'être
écouté j'ai été espionné par od DF on a
retrouvé on a retrouvé la copie de mon
ordinateur dans les locaux de DF qui
c'est qui les a retrouvé euh la justice
h donc la justice a fait son travail il
n'empêche que j'ai été espionné et
j'étais un des responsables le
responsable des campagnes de Greenpeace
qui est en prison maintenant ah mais
personne nétait en prison il les les
barbouses ont été sanctionné pour des
raisons totalement hallucinantes alors
que EDF avait pris le maximum en
première instance EDF a été relaxé en
appel à la Cour de Versailles qui aime
qui adore visiblement énormément ce type
d'entreprise parce que à un moment donné
je pense que alors que le le le le le le
l'argumentation juridique était
imbattable je dire les types ils ont la
copie de mon ordinateur dans les bureaux
de DF ça n'est pas pour leur intérêt
personnel donc c'était pour l'intérêt de
DF donc le lien juridique était évident
mais à un moment donné des juges ont
considéré que
Greenpeace parce que Greenpeace fait
aussi des actions de désobéissance
civile était illégitime a continué à
exister dans la société ça c'est pas non
plus une preuve de démocratie je dis pas
que la France est une dictature de basse
intensité et je dis pourtant que le cœur
de la démocratie le cœur de la
démocratie ce sont les citoyens qui
contrôlent l'État c'est jamais l'État
qui contrôle les citoyens ça ça
s'appelle pas la démocratie mais c'est
pas non plus la dictature on est en
démocratie en France est-ce que vous
avez l'impression que le citoyen
contrôle son
état on est dans ce que certains
appellent la postdémocratie c'est-à-dire
qu'à la fois on a des institutions qui
fonctionnent on élit euh des
représentants ils siègent à l'Assemblée
au Sénat on a élu un président de la
République qui fait qui va finir son
quinquena donc au fond les institutions
existent et fonctionne mais on est ce
qu'on appelle dans la postdémocratie
parce qu'en fait toutes les institutions
il y a plus aucune énergie vitale dedans
et que les citoyens considèrent que on
se fout d'eux et que quoi qu'il vote de
toute façon ça ne change rien que c'est
des exercices de combat presque de
d'agence de communication plus que de
modèle de société donc de ce point de
vue-là on n'est pas on est dans une
démocratie qui fonctionne terriblement
mal et moi quand je dis que je veux
changer de constitution qu'à la fois on
passe un régime parlementaire qu'il soit
élu à la proportionnelle que l'assemblée
ressemble à la France donc à la fois
dans ses âges comme dans sa diversité
quand je dis queil faut multiplier les
votations citoyennes les conférences de
consensus les assemblées tirer au sort
justement pour que entre les élections
les citoyens puissent s'emparer des
décisions quand je veux redistribuer
voir financer les contrepouvoirs
l'expertise je dis 5 % de tous les
financements de la politique
représentative donc financement des
partis politiques financement des
campagnes électorales les réserves
parlementaires 5 % de tous ces
montants-là doivent aller vers des
associations qui puissent travailler en
contreexertise ou en expertise sur les
projets de loi ou qui puisse proposer
des projets de loi donc moi je veux en
permanence repartager le pouvoir que les
citoyens et les sooens se réempart du
pouvoir quand je suis sur la transition
énergétique c'est plutôt que le pétrole
et le gaz et le nucléaire dont on a
parlé tout à l'heure des citoyens qui
s'organisent ensemble on n pas parlé du
nucléire non ça c'est é l'autre plateau
télé ça ah bon bon en tout cas on a
parlé du pétrole et du gaz donc bah si
on a parlé de la dépendance à la Russie
et au Pétro monarchie du golf notre
dépendance elle est aussi très largement
liée à notre addiction au pétrole quand
je dis que les citoyens se réemparent à
l'échelle locale des enjeux énergétiques
qui consomment un peu
moins poser la question concernant la
responsabilité des politiques c'estàdire
que on trouve nous que les politiques
c'est qui nous bah la société civile
d'accord il y a pas assez de
répercussion alors on va pas tomber dans
la Corée du Nord parce que sinon on va
encore prendre de la dictature mais en
Corée du Nord quand vous respectez pas
vos promesses vous prenez une balle que
vous êtes vous êtes obligé de payer en
France on fait comment pour rendre les
les politiques comptables de leurs
promesses mais il y a des élections moi
je suis pour que les électeurs ils
fassent pas en permanence tous pourris
et qu'il soient prêt à revoter pour ceux
qui sont réellement pourris c'est pas il
y a des lois mais attendez il y a des
lois il y a des lois sur la
corruption il y a des médias qui font
particulièrement leur boulot pour
dénoncer les conflits d'intérêts pour
dénoncer la corruption quel média par
exemple méia part M part fait son
travail et qui d'autre bah ils font déjà
ils font déjà un GR travail mais de temp
ça sort dans d'autres journaux mais ce
que je veux dire c'est que il y a aussi
une information qui existe sur un C
nombre de responsables politiques qui
sont pris en train de
fauter et la loi parfois les sanctionne
ou pas les sanctionne pas ce que je
trouve dramatique aussi c'est que les
citoyens sont prêts parfois à aller
revoter pour eux moi j' rend compre
beaucoup on me dit souvent les
politiques vous êtes tous pourris je dis
pourquoi vous me dites ça à moi moi j'ai
fait j'ai pas fait de la politique toute
ma vie vous avez un casier judiciaire
j'ai eu un casier judiciaire parce que
je suis rentré en zodiaque un zodiaque
Greenpeace dans la base de sous-marin
nucléaire de Lille longue pour dénoncer
l'illégalité de notre programme de
dissuasion nucléaire au regard du traité
de non prolifération mais le le c'était
il y a plus de 10 ans donc il y a mais
ce que je veux dire c'est que on peut
pas être il faut qu' aussi que les
citoyens se prennent en main et disent
un politique qui triche plus jamais
est-ce que c'est pas trop tard je crois
pas je je sais pas ce que ça veut dire
trop tard ce que je vois c'est que notre
elle glisse elle est sur un toboggan
toboggan du repli identitaire toboggan
des
communautarismes
toboggan de la certitude du déclin
collectif et de la peur du déclassement
individuel ça on le voit mais c'est
aussi parce que des gouvernements sont
là qui ont renoncé à combattre pour la
justice sociale contre les
discriminations contre la dégradation
environnementale et j'aimerais tellement
que les les les électeur à un moment
donné et je dis pas que c'est pas aussi
ma responsabilité ils disent mais
pourquoi enfin je je suis toujours
surpris qu'il votent pour les mêmes qui
sont là depuis 40 ans qu' des recettes
qui sont usées jusqu'à la corde qui
n'ont pas répondu à la question du
chômage qui ne répondent pas à la
question démocratique qui ne répondent
pas à la question environnementale et
pourtant ils vont toujours
majoritairement vers les mêmes candidats
donc c'est ils acceptent soit ils votent
plus mais ils acceptent au fond parfois
aussi un vote de renon ement ou font un
vote de colère moi dans cette campagne
ce que j'aimerais c'est que les
électeurs ils aillent vers des votes
d'adhésion qu'ils aillent vers des votes
de conviction qui se disent ces
solutionsl elles sont positives et
pourquoi pas les voter vers des solution
positives plutôt que toujours les mêmes
oui bon
euh vous êtes dans l'écologie oui est-ce
que vous êtes d'accord pour appliquer
les mêmes protocoles de sécurité du
nucléaire à la finance et à la politique
quand on voit l'état de du parc
nucléaire français quand on voit quand
on lit les rapports de l'Autorité de
sûreté nucléaire qui met en garde
énormément
EDF et les autorités pour dire on a un
gros problème de sécurité je me dis
qu'effectivement le nucléaire est aussi
mal sécurisé aussi mal protégé que les
citoyens de la finance est-ce que vous
pensez que les les gens travaillant dans
la finance manant des des milliards à
chaque transaction devrait être soumis à
un contrôle de
stupéfiant j'en sais rien euh est-ce que
vous êtes d'accord pour qu'un trader qui
est gavé de Cooke joue 4 milliards par
jour pas c'est pas c'est pas c'est pas
sur ce terrainlà que j'irai d'accord je
vous pose juste la question est-ce que
pour vous un trader ne doit pas non mais
il y a des lois pour ça il y a des lois
pour ça donc c'est pas le sujet vous
savez il y avait un excellent article du
Wall Street Journal qui disait en fait
la finance connaît deux états l'euphorie
et la panique ouais et l'euphorie et la
panique sont deux symptômes de la
dépression la Maniac
déépression ce qui domine ces deux
étapes il y a le dén ce qui domine le
monde est une
maladie psychique et c'est dramatique
c'està-dire qu'en fait on a on le disait
tout à l'heure sur les banques si on
narrive pas
à
redimensionner la finance pour qu'elle
serve l'économie et qu'elle soit pas en
surplomb de l'économie et aujourd'hui en
surplom de la politique on n'en sortira
pas donc c'est la taxe sur les
transactions financières c'est la lutte
contre les paradis fiscaux et je suis
très heureux que y compris John Paly qui
était que j'avais soutenu à Dax et qui
avait volé les chaise à la BNP pour
dénoncer l'évasion fiscale est été
relaxé pour le coup
euh évidemment je l'ai dit séparation il
faut il faut que tout ça revienne dans
une petite boite par moi je vous parle
d'analyser ceux qui gèrent votre argent
leur faire passer comme un pilote
d'avion un test de stupéfiant pour ou
contre je je j'en sais rien enfin là je
je comprends pas je comprends pas parce
que moi le système si vous voulez
pourquoi ces gens-là prennent des
potentiellement des stupéfiants moi je
suis pas dans la finance pourquoi ces
gens-là prennent profondément des des
stupéfiants c'est parce qu'il au fond on
leur a donné un
permis de jouer avec notre argent avec
notre notre économie avec nos vies et ce
permisl c'est des gens extrêmement
sérieux peut-être qui prennent pas de la
cocaïne mais qui apparaissent tous les
jours à la télé qui détiennent des
médias et qui au fond apparaissent
toujours très propres sur eux moi c'est
à la source que je VO allais moi KIRVIEL
je m'en fous ce type ne m'intéresse pas
ce qui m'intéresse c'est le comportement
de la Société Générale qui dans quand
ils sont en conseil d'administration
prennent des décisions qui vont à
l'encontre de du bien être de la société
et faire passer des contrôles de
stupéfiants au politiques mais vous
voulez faire passer des contrôles de
stupéfiants à tout le monde c'est ça
drôle ça sur quand on a le feu nucléaire
sous le
doigt j'en sais rien moi je je je moi je
suis pour qu'il y ait un un un alors si
pour quand on est quand on est président
de la République je suis pour qu'il y
ait un comité de médecins
indépendant don l'indépendance est fondé
sur la loi qui examine régulièrement la
santé du président de la République ou
de la présidente de la République et qui
émettent un bulletin de santé pas pour
dire euh il a un sale bouton sous le
genou gauche mais pour dire il est en
capacité mentale physique psychique
d'exercer ses responsabilités parce
qu'on sait que jusqu'à maintenant les
contrôles médicaux des présidents de la
République ont toujours été totalement
faussé ou intercepté par la
CIA vous connaissez l'histoire avec
Pompidou écoutez il était vraiment
malade de toute façon para il paraît que
la CIA savait même l'état de santé de
Staline à travers c'est ce qu'il faisait
aux toilettes donc si je vous dis je
vais vous faire passer un contrôle de
stupéfiant de C drogues est-ce que vous
acceptez ah sans problème sans problème
sans problème toutes les drogues à
toutes les drogues oui vous pas de
problème ah non j'ai aucun problème vous
savez j'assume parfaitement d'avoir fumé
quand j'étais plus jeune pour savoir si
vous êtes pas au sous cou sous speed ça
non non non mais j'assume parfaitement
d'avoir fumé quand j'étais plus jeune
aujourd'hui je reconnais que je suis
plutôt pour un bon verre de vin voilà
c'est aussi peut-être le le l'âge avec
l'âge on change un peu de de de de de
plaisir d'accord les migrants qu'est-ce
qu'on fait alors on va on va dissocier
réfugiés et migrants économiques ou on
les met on les met tous dans le même sac
ce sont des réfugiés économiques et des
réfug sur on commence par pas les mettre
dans un sac si on peut commencer à ne
pas les mettre dans des sacs ceux qu'on
met dans des sacs c'est ceux qui son en
Méditerrané pass c'est pas ce qui se
passe en ce moment dans DIN c'est ceux
qui sont m il y en a pas qu'
Méditerranée il y en a à Mayotte aussi
non oui il y en a aussi effectivement
quelle est la première porte
d'entrée des flux migratoires en
Europe alors aujourd'hui c'est quand
même ça reste quand même Grèce Italie
Mayotte c'est beaucoup mais c'est pas au
niveau de la Grèce et de l'Italie
notamment depuis la crise syrienne on
est à quel niveau là en Grèce en Italie
bah avec l'accord avec Erdogan qui a a
quand même un peu verrouillé euh pour le
coup euh la frontière de manière
d'ailleurs on a délégué à Erdogan notre
humanité nos obligations euh au regard
du droit international on fait des
choses et dans on met les réfugiés dans
des camps où y compris il y a des
marques de vêtements qui sont en train
de s'installer à côté pour les faire
travailler pour rien et euh ces camp-là
à peine les Nations Unies peuvent les
visiter donc on est on est sur quelque
chose de totalement inhumain et
totalement irresponsable du point de vue
des valeurs euh de l'Union européenne
mais pour le coup on est maintenant sur
quelques centaines alors qu'avant on
était sur des milliers par semaine donc
on a un peu bloqué le flux on voit que
ceux qui arrivent de Méditerranée se
malheureusement se noie beaucoup plus
qu'avant parce qu'à force de prétendre
vouloir contrôler les passeurs en fait
on met les gens dans des situations de
plus en plus difficiles de plus en plus
risqué et l'enjeu c'est évidemment si on
parle des réfugiés que l'Europe assum sa
responsabilité ses obligations et son
devoir humanitaire qui est d'accueillir
des réfugiés à partir du moment où
évidemment ce sont des survivants vous
estimez le flux à
combien pour les trois prochaines années
j'en sais rien j'en sais rien on est
vous voyez bien que on s on s'est mis en
faisant l'accord avec Erdogan on s'est
mis sous une sous sous une en fait on
s'est laissé prendre en otage par
Erdogan c'est qu'on accepte qu'il monte
en dictature la la Turquie qui devienent
de plus en plus autocratique qui
reviennent de plus en plus sur les
droits parce que il contrôle 2 millions
et demi de réfugiés si Erdogan lâche
toutes les Vanes des réfugiés syriens on
peut imaginer que c'est de c'est des
millions qui de nouveau arrivent sur le
territoire européen ce qu'il faut c'est
espérer qu'à un moment donné on va
imposer
et la fin de la guerre en Syrie et
qu'une parte des Syriens vont pouvoir
retourner chez eux et puis cell qui veut
continuer à s'installer en Europe puiss
s'y intégrer les migrants
économiques quelle est la question là
vous m'avez parlé des 30 % de migrants
de guerre afghan syriens soudanais ouais
iraakien maintenant on va parler ou ou
je vi dire éitréen ouais les autres et
ben les autres on a un devoir y compris
là euh c'est notre intérêt de société
que notre intérêt que la la la l'Europe
reste une terre
d'immigration c'est une belle partie de
notre richesse collective que d'avoir
des migrants à la fois ça booste
l'économie et ça permet à la fois une
diversité un enrichissement mutuel de
l'ensemble vous entendez et pardon par
booster
l'économie dans la bouche dans la bouche
d'un écologiste c'est c'est sympa pas
entendre vous êtes pour une société de
croissance ou de décroissance moi je
suis pour une société qui vit bien donc
c'est la décroissance de des maladies
liées aux pollutions c'est la
décroissance des énergies carbonées et
du nucléaire pour éviter et le
dérèglement climatique et le risque
nucléaire c'est la décroissance de nos
prédations sur la biodiversité qui
génère l'extinction des espèces c'est la
réduction de notre prédation sur les
ressources qui construisent des
dictatures et du maldéveloppement
partout dans le monde donc ça c'est de
la décroissance maintenant je suis pour
la croissance de notre santé qu'elle
soit mieux protégée je suis pour la
croissance des énergies renouvelables
booster notre économie dans quel sens je
comprends pas bien parce que quand vous
êtes les migrants qui arrivent le plus
souvent ils arrivent avec une telle
énergie qui participe de l'activité
économique ils participent à la
dynamiser parce qu'ils en ont envie ils
viennent pas pour toucher les
allocations vous imaginez passer des
mois pour migrer se retrouver dans des
conditions incroyables et venir là pour
toucher des allocation c'est idiot à
dire et c'est des gens qui apportent de
l'intelligence qui apportent des une
culture différente une vision différente
et qui permettent démétissage et la
dynamisation de la société et dans la
société il y a aussi l'économie donc je
je veux toujours dire que dans
l'histoire de l'humanité les migrations
n'ont jamais été un
fardeau on en fait quoi on les
naturalise on leur donne un permis on
fait quoi mais la loi est claire c'est
dire qu'à partir du moment où ils ont
travaillé un certain nombre d'années
dans notre pays ils ont le droit à être
naturalisés et avant il pas les
naturaliser dès qu'ils arrivent et avant
et avant on leur donne un permis on leur
on fait quoi ah moi je suis pour qu'ils
aient un un quand ils ont quand ils sont
sur notre territoire qu'ils a moi je
suis j'ai toujours été pour le visa
multi-entrée c'est qu'ils viennent ils
ont un boulot ils ont pas de boulot ils
peuvent retourner chez eux parce que
toute la difficulté aussi c'est qu'à
force de de rendre les conditions
d'entrée en Europe totalement
restrictive en fait les gens
s'enquistent sur les territoires parce
que justement ils n'ont plus cette
capacité à à se mouvoir et un des un des
visas qu'il faut absolument développer
c'est le visa notamment pour les
étudiants vous savez que les
statistiques françaises sont totalement
dingues puisque on met les étudiants
dans les chiffres des migrants donc et
c'est 40 quasiment 40 % des migrants il
faut favoriser justement ces visas
d'aller-retour pour faire en sorte que
ceux qui viennent étudier à la fois ils
s'enrichissent mais qu'il puissent
retourner dans leur pays pour que leur
pays profite de la formation qu'ils ont
eu mais qu'on puisse continuer nous
aussi en profiter qu'il puisse en
permanence aller d'un pays à l'autre
pour justement bénéficier et qu'on
bénéficie tous de cet enrichissement
mutuel on fait un petit mon du coocalan
le nuclée
on a combien de réacteurs sur le
territoire on a 58 réacteurs combien ça
coûte de les
décommissionner de les alors décomission
c'est quoi les démantelés les démantel
ouais ah les démantelés aujourd'hui le
chiffre de la France est totalement
tordu puisque on estime entre 3 et 400
millions un le démantellement d'un
réacteur quand l'expérience en
Grande-Bretagne et les chif de la
Commission européenne on est plutôt
entre 1,2 et 1,5 milliards et c'est pour
pour ça par exemple que
EDF qui a osé dire que comme ils sont
pas capables de financer le
démantèlement la France engagerait le
démantellement de ses réacteurs
nucléaires au siècle prochain une
entreprise qui a 60 ans qui a développé
une technologie qui va nous laisser pend
des centaines de milliers d'années des
déchets radioactifs partout sur notre
territoire au se dire nous reportons
d'un siècle le démantèlement de nos
réacteurs nucléaires donc c'est un des
cooups cachés du nucléaire et ça va nous
coûter bonbons mais ça il faudra le
faire alors à quelle
échéance les écologistes sont pour une
sortie du nucléaire en 20 ans en 20 ans
quel coût le coût mais c'est que du
bénéfice aujourd'hui mettre ne serait-ce
que mettre à niveau nos centrales
nucléairire par rapport au risque dit
Fukushima donc séisme inondation c'est
selon la Cour des comptes 100 milliards
d'euros on a Ed qui a déjà endetté à un
peu moins de 40 milliards d'euros eDF va
investir sur les PR en Grande-Bretagne
les deux pr dinkley point on est à 22 23
24 milliards d'euros tout ça est financé
soit par le contribuable soit par le
consommateur c'est devenu un gouffre
financier extraordinaire le nucléaire en
sortir et choisir des énergies
renouvelables qui sont aujourd'hui plus
compétitives moins chè au prix du kilwh
c'est gagner beaucoup d'argent et c'est
réduire le risque et en plus ça crée 4 à
5 fois plus d'emplois que le nucléaire
c'est tout
bnef les conditions d'élevage les choses
comme ça la L214 pour où pour vous c'est
les terroristes c'est quoi ah j'étais
encore la semaine dernière avec eux
certainement pas des terroristes des
amis euh moi j'étis dans les campagnes
de Greenpeace on avait déjà des actions
sur les les espèces en voie de
disparition j'ai toujours été copain
avec bourgrin du bour le travail qu'
fait la LPO notamment sur la question de
la chasse et de la protection des
animaux
L214 apporte quelque chose de nouveau
qui est un éclairage
violent violent sur les conditions
d'abattage mais pas violent parce que
ils ont envie de faire la violence parce
que les les conditions d'abattage sont
devenues extrêmement violentes violentes
pour tout le monde hein parce que les
les abattoirs sont tellement concentrés
que même pour les gens qui qui travaille
là-dedans c'est absolument abominable et
mais la l'étape qui manque un peu dans
le débat et que je veux mettre en
lumière dans la campagne c'est les
conditions d'élevage parce que la mort
c'est toujours traumatique ça peut être
absolument dégueulasse c'est ce que
montre L214 mais de toute façon c'est
traumatique la mort vous mangez de la
viande je mange de la viande et je pense
que je je je suis en train de faire un
chemin sur ma consommation de viande
parce que la réalité c'est que on n'est
pas au Burkina Faso on n'est pas au bal
j'aime bien les politiques qui
commencent leur phrases par la réalité
non parce que je vais vous expliquer où
il faut j'ai vécu j'ai vécu au Burkina
Faso j'ai vécu au Bangladesh je sais la
nécessité des protéines animales quand
on est en France aujourd'hui on peut
vivre sans protéine animale on sait
faire donc ça signifie que la mort et la
souffrance des animaux pour qu'on ait de
la viande et uniquement lié à notre
plaisir gustatif on pourrait s'en passer
et donc moi ça m'amène à faire un chemin
qui est un chemin de réduction très
forte de ma consommation de viande rouge
y compris parce que c'est pas bon du
tout pour le climat de manger moins de
viande de manger plus de viande blanche
bio parce que c'est meilleur pour le
climat et que les conditions d'élevage
sont moins dramatiques mais c'est un
chemin qu'on doit tous faire sans
culpabiliser qu'est-ce que vous pensez
de si Shepard si wat c'est très bien
c'est très bien vous savez moi j'étais à
Greenpeace donc si Sheepard il y a
toujours un petit une petite concurrence
entre Greenpeace et s Shepard sur les
campagnes contre la chasse à la baleine
eux eux ils ils investissent pas 30 % de
leur budget en communication ouais enfin
bon là c'est faites attention à ça parce
que c'est pas c'est pas une c'est pas
c'est à la fois c'est pas des bons
chiffres et deuxiè je sais pas moi je je
sais plus ça fait longtemps que j'ai
quitté Greenpeace on doit être sur un
cout du fonctionnement administratif qui
doit être autour normalement des 10 15 %
après quand vous faites une la
communication si Shepard aussi fait de
la communication ils sont sur ils sont
sur les festivals ils ont des goodies
ils ont ils font des t-shirt tout ça
fait partie de la communication quand
vous voulez convaincre une société
qu'elle doit changer quand vous faites
des actions c'est très bien surtout si
il y a des médias qui les reprennent
quand vous faites vous allez voir les
responsables politiques tout ça mais un
moment quand vous voulez que la la
société vous soutienne et ben oui il
faut faire de la communication quand
vous faites une émission ici moi là
qu'est-ce que je fais à part de la
communication c'est pour convaincre les
personnes qui qui vont regarder
l'émission donc c'est aussi de la
communication combien vous gagnez un
député européen a des indemnité de
6 400 maintenant euros par mois net net
parce que je paye l'impôt européen
d'accord vous payez pas votre impôt en
France la le le le le système pour les
députés européens c'est que vous payez
l'impôt européen et le vous faites votre
déclaration en France l'administration
fiscale recalcule ce que serait votre
impôt en France si et notamment si vous
payez moins d'impôts européens que vous
payez en France vous payez aussi en plus
l'impôt français est-ce que vous faites
comme certains députés européens à faire
semblant de pointer pour toucher votre
indemnisation journalière si vous
regardez tous les chiffres qui sont
sortis il y a eu un reportage il y a pas
longtemps à la télé notamment sur tous
les candidats sur tous les candidats à
l'élection présidentiell qui sont
députés européens vous verrez que je
suis à 70 % de présence au Parlement
européen donc à Bruxelles et à
Strasbourg quand la plupart de mes
concurrents sont entre 10 et 20 %. donc
je fais mon boulot avant d'être ici
j'étais à à Bruxelles pour en commission
du commerce international pour voter
contre le traité de libre échange avec
le Canada dans cette même commission
siège Marine Le Pen comme d'habitude
elle n'était pas là pour voter mais ça
l'empêchera pas de dire qu'elle est
contre le ca mais elle fait pas le
boulot pour que empêcher le CA d'arriver
on s'en fout de Marine Le Pen on lui a
proposé de venir elle vient pas euh oui
mais elle est candidate et aujourd'hui
elle est souvent en tête des intentions
de vote donc on parlait on parlait la
faute à qui mais la faute la faute à
plein de gens la flotte à plein de gens
je l'ai dit tout à l'heure je l'ai dit
tout à l'heure à partir du moment où les
gouvernements renonce à se battre contre
les inégalités à se battre pour que tout
le monde accède à un logement à se
battre pour qu'il y ait des services
publics sur tous les territoires à se
battre pour qu'il a de l'emploi sur tous
les territoires à se battre contre les
discriminations qu'est-ce qu'on faire de
la dette par pardon qu'est-ce qu'on va
faire de la dette française
euh alors la dette française moi j'ai
toujours considéré que il y avait une
partie de la dette française qui de qui
était assez largement illégitime on l'a
répudie attendez j'essaie d'expliquer
notamment toute la dette qui qui est
issue du sauvetage des banques pendant
la après la crise financière de 2008
j'ai toujours dit c'est vraiment la
dette qu'il faut mutualiser à l'échelle
européenne on retire ces 20 à 30 % de
notre dette 30 % de de de de de de oui
qui doit être mutualisé à l'échelle
européenne et qu'on rééchelonne
indéfiniment je veux dire les l'histoire
des sociétés ça a été aussi
régulièrement de supprimer la dette ou
de trouver des moyens de ne pas
rembourser la dette et aujourd'hui
d'avoir sauvé les banques ça a permis à
ces acteursl de survivre et aujourd'hui
c'est eux qui participent à l'évasion
fiscale 1000 milliards d'euros d'évasion
fiscale en Europe 60 à 80 milliards
d'évasion fiscale à l'échelle française
et notamment du fait des banques c'est
profondément scandaleux fa raison de
plus pour pas rembourser les dettes on
fait quoi alors pour les serrer les
l'optim l'optimisation fiscale on fait
quoi pour serrer un petit peu ça 1 la
lutte contre les paradis fiscaux ouais
on lutte comment ah bah c'est toute la
transparence déjà sur les activités
bancaires financières dans les paradis
fiscaux donc qu'on sache y compris que
le public puisse savoir quels sont les
activités que la BNP par exemple a aux
îles Caillan combien d'activités en
volume combien de personnel comment il
payent les impôts tout ça qu'il ait au
moins la transparence moi je suis pour
que toutes les les acteurs bancaires
financiers ou les grandes entreprises
qui vont dans les paradis fiscaux soit
exclus de tous les marchés publics
est-ce que la France c'est un parende ça
c'est un point important parce qu'on
parlait de la démocratie tout à l'heure
aujourd'hui un juge qui veut enquêter
sur une entre
le parquet financier qui ve enquêter sur
une entreprise qui fait de l'évasion
fiscale doit demander l'autorisation à
Bercy et ben moi je veux faire sauter ce
verrou de berc y compris quand les quand
des des groupes quand des des des
associations veulent faire attaquer des
entreprises pour évasion fiscale alors
les class action les les les groupes de
d'action qu'est-ce que vous pensez des
Civic tech qu'est-ce que vous pensez
qu'est-ce que vous propose pour que la
population se sente plus impliquée dans
ce processus démocratique et ben j'ai
une proposition ça tombe bien c'est que
1 % du budget d'investissement de l'État
soit en budget participatif à travers
les plateformes Civic tech c'està-dire
que comme on a les budgets participatifs
dans les municipalités c'est qu'en fait
les citoyens ont des projets ils les
construisent ou les construisent à
travers des plateformes il il
hiérarchisent les projets qui doivent
être retenus et c'est financé par le
budget de la ville et ben je faux ver ça
à l'échelle nationale donc c'est 1 % du
budget d'investissement de l'État
combien c'est on est autour c'est
toujours très compliqué le budget
d'investissement de l'État mais on est
autour de 600 millions d'euros et donc
c'est ça passe à travers des plateformes
Civic tech la taxe carbone pour comment
on gère et on régule ça benah on gère à
la fois déjà on purge complètement le
marché européen du carbone qui
aujourd'hui la tonne de de de carbone
elle à 45 € ça n'envoie aucun signal à
l'économie pour sortir du carbone donc
il faut purger tous les quotas excessifs
pour que le le prix du carbone remonte
et puis c'est une taxe carbone à
l'échelle de notre pays il faut aller
vers les 100 € on considère que le le
prix qui commence à
inciter sérieusement à changer les
stratégies d'investissement c'est autour
de 100 € mais surtout de montrer qu'on a
une détermination à y aller donc c'est
vers ça qu'il faut aller les lobby euh
Parlement européen vous vous en voyez
souvent comment ça se fait que les
lobbyistes ils aient le droit de
circuler comme ça ils ont droit de
circuler partout à partir du moment où
ils son enregistré moi mon sujet c'est
pas c'est un fantasme l'interdiction des
lobby parce que il y a toujours des
intérêts économiques qui sont
représentés moi ce que je veux c'est que
soit organisé et assainiie la relation
entre les lobby et les responsablebl
politique les lobis il y en a partout he
ils sont à Bery ils sont à Matignon ils
sont à l'Élysée tous les jours ils font
le siège de toutes les administrations à
l'échelle locale à l'échelle nationale à
l'échelle européenne le seul sujet c'est
que un à chaque fois que vous rencontrez
un lobby c'est noté c'est transparent et
c'est sanctionné si vous l'indiquez pas
deuxièmement supprimer évidemment
combattre durement la corruption et
supprimer tous les conflits d'intérêts
dans toutes les agences qui à la fois
dans les dans les administrations mais
dans les agences pseudo indépendantes et
publiqu qui conseillent les
gouvernements Baroso Goldman sax c'est à
profondément scandaleux mais quand tous
les conseillers économiques des
présidents que ce soit Hollande et
Sarkozy finissent par pantoufler dans
des banques une fois qu'ils sont sortis
du cabinet du Président de la République
c'est aussi préjudiciable à l'intérêt
général qu'un Barroso parce que c'est
eux qui font les c'est eux qui font les
politiques et c'est eux qui expliquent
en permanence qu'on peut pas s'en
prendre aux banques qu'on peut pas
réguler la finance qu'il faut faire
toujours moins en matière de contrôle et
ben c'est eux qui après touchent le
jackpot quand ils vont quand ils
retournent dans la banque bon en 2017
vous avez votter qui au deème tour j'en
sais rien je sais pas qui sera au
deuxième tour vous savez vous comment
vous savez qu' sera au 2è tour en je
sais que vous serez pas au deuxème tour
et ben vous verrez on
verra pas une petite piste bah non
pourquoi on est obligé d'avoir un parti
écologiste en France parce qu'il y a pas
d'écologie sans écologiste regardez ce
gouvernement il a promis de faire mon et
merveill en matière de protection de
l'environnement d'écologie il a eu une
opportunité extraordinaire avec la cop21
et l'accord de Paris sur le climat
d'engager enfin la transition
énergétique qui est en plus créatrice
d'emploi et encore aujourd'hui on
apprend que ce gouvernement a priori ne
fermera même pas fessenhe qui est
vraiment le petit bout du du petit bout
du petit bout de la transition
énergétique qui était gouvernement qui
était au gouvernement en tant
qu'écologiste y avait Cécile Duflou
Jean-Vincent plac alors Jean-Vincent
plac il est pas membre d'Europe Écologie
Les ver il est pas membre du mouvement
écologiste d'accord ben Cécile Duflot
elle y était Pascal campfin parce qu'on
avait un contrat que ce contrat
prévoyait justement de réduire
sérieusement le nucléaire de réduire les
pesticides et comme ce gouvernement n'a
rien fait et ben on en est sorti et s'il
y a pas d'écologiste à l'échelle locale
que ça soit un militant associatif ou un
militant politique si on a encore un peu
près une eau potable si on a pas de gaz
de chiste dans notre pays si on n pas
d'OGM si il y a des choses positives qui
se font c'est parce qu'il y a des
écologiste qu'est-ce qu'on fait avec les
terroristes et l'état d'urgence l'état
d'urgence je suis contre je veux dire
l'état d'urgence qu'est-ce que ça fait
en tant que militant d'être fiché parce
que vous devez être fiché vous non ça me
fait d'une certaine façon ça me fait
rire ça montre toute la bêtise de ces
systèmes et ça montre queon ne concentre
pas les moyens sur les vraies personnes
dangereuses l'état d'urgence c'est une
diversion politique vous n'avez pas un
expert en terrorisme pas un expert en
sécurité qui considère qu'aujourd'hui
l'état d'urgence c'est utile simplement
parce que au fond il y a une telle
surenchère dans la politique autour de
ça qu'il y a pas un président qui est
capable de dire ça sert à rien revenons
au régime normal donnons et soyons
efficace dans la lutte contre le
terrorisme à l'échelle française et en
coopération à l'échelle on fait quoi
pour être efficace pour le terrorisme et
on met quoi comme politique de
contrreadicalisation alors qu'est-ce
qu'on fait pour être efficace en matière
de terrorisme c'est qu'on réinstalle la
police de proximité la police qui
connaît tous les coins on a une police
de proximité qui est guidée par du
renseignement qui est aussi décentralisé
à l'échelle des territoires pour
identifier suivre les suspects ça veut
dire une coopération européenne
en matière de de terroriste je l'ai dit
moi je suis pour un FBI européen je suis
pour un parquet européen je suis pour
une coopération des agences de
renseignement européennes pour être
efficace et puis c'est plus de moyens
pour la justice qui est aujourd'hui en
voie de clochardisation les politiques
de contreradicalisation en amont vous
m'avez dit bah les politiques de
contre-radicalisation il y a des
associations des expérimentations des
expériences qui sont faites contre la
radicalisation et qui doivent nous
enseigner sur la façon de le faire c'est
évidemment éviter de mettre n'importe
qui n'importe comment en prison parce
qu'on voit un certain nombre de jeunes
qui tombent dans la radicalisation mais
qui est pas une radicalisation
religieuse ça c'est du baratin la
plusupart le le le le le le le le
parcours
c'est délinquant
prison
radicalisation voyage terrorisme il y a
pas de spiritualité là-dedans c'est
simplement des losers absolus qui se
retrouvent dans la société sans aucune
capacité d'identification sinon au pire
et c'est déjà une façon de de lutter
contre la radicalisation c'est de faire
en sorte que nos quartiers nos écoles et
toutes les services publics qu'il qu'il
méritent pas d'autres mots à rajouter
sur le
terrorisme pour dire quoi qu'est-ce que
fr j'ai parlé j'ai parlé de la
complaisance vis-à-vis des
pétromonarchies du golf et de leur leur
vision
faschisante fabus dit Jabal nostra fait
du bon
boulot on est ce qui est terrible en
Syrie c'est que le début ce sont des
manifestations pacifiques de citoyens
qui veulent plus de démocratie qui
veulent plus de liberté à partir du
moment où on soutient des
pétromonarchies je l'ai dit qu' une
vision faschisante de la religion qu'on
laisse ou qu'on finalement à la fin ce
sont des dictature qui gagne vous avez
toujours le pire c'est toujours le pire
quand on quand on réduit à rien la
démocratie vous avez les dictature et le
terrorisme et le djihadisme c'est comme
c'est ça qui est en train d'arriver dans
R je trouve que vous avez
une une vision un
peu c'est un peu nébuleux pour moi votre
perception de l' vous avez déjà éta sur
dans le coin ah ben j'ai été par exemple
en Libye y compris pendant le conflit la
guerre était pas terminée vous avez
rencontré qui là-bas j'ai rencontraer
les groupes qui se battaient notamment
contre contre contre les troupes de
Khaddafi et en Syrie vous avez été aussi
non comment vous avez rencontré les
troupes libyennes ben j'étais à ce
moment-là vous aviez un fixeur au sein
d'une délégation
européenne de parlementaires européens
écolo qui se sont rendus notamment sur
toute la partie berbère mais aussi à à
Tripoli et puis on est descendu jusqu'à
Misrata
voilà on va passer sur la Chine très
bien passe sur la Chine qu'est-ce qu'on
fait avec la Chine et ben la Chine c'est
comme la Russie il faut montrer que faut
installer un rapport de force qui nous
permet de peser vous avez fait un
rapport de force avec la chinois les
Chinois bien sûr comment vous avez
organisé ça et ben par exemple moi je me
suis battu au Parlement européen contre
le dumping chinois sur toute l'industrie
photovoltaïque qui a tué toute notre
industrie à cût de subvention publique
en Chine il suffisait que l'Europe soit
forte et comme les États-Unis imposent
des droits de douane de 250 % on aurait
maintenu les emplois ici donc c'est
aussi par ce rapport de force là qu'on
intervient le problème de l'Union
européenne c'est qu'aujourd'hui elle a
une politique commerciale commune mais
qu'elle n'a pas de diplomatie commune
c'est que on voit les chinois ne parlent
jamais à l'Union européne ils viennent
dans les différents pays ils promettent
des milliards de projets des achats des
investissements et ça per ça ça permet
d'obtenir au fond le que l'Europe soit
un
ventreemou diplomatique mais ça ça n'est
que de la responsabilité de nos chefs
d'État et de gouvernement de se mettre
ensemble pour imposer plus d'équilibre
dans les relations commerciales avec la
Chine et une des mesures que je propose
également c'est que n'entre plus sur le
marché européen des produit issu de pays
qui ne respectent pas la liberté
syndicale parce que c'est pas du
protectionnisme du certain une façon
c'est protéger les salariés là-bas et
c'est protéger les salariés ici
qu'est-ce qu'on fait avec Donald
Trump Donald Trump compliqué ça va être
extrêmement compliqué si Donald Trump
veut absolument s'exonérer de la lutte
contre le dérèglement climatique faudra
mettre une taxe aux frontières de
l'Union européenne on peut pas nous
imposer à nos entreprises et c'est
légitime de de de d'investir pour
réduire leurs émissions de gaz à effet
de serre et accepter que les les les
firmes américaines soient exonéré d'une
telle discipline donc il va falloir
aussi
la pas montrer les dents au sens on
n'est pas en guerre mais établir un
rapport de force pour faire en sorte que
les États-Unis ne soient pas récompensés
de leur isolationisme ou euh de du fait
qu'ils tournent le dos à leur
responsabilité planétaire en matière de
lutte contre le dérèglement climatique
notamment est-ce que vous arrivez à
modéliser la dislocation géopolitique
mondiale est-ce que déjà première
question et deuxème question la
dislocation européenne est-ce que pour
vous c'est modélisable ou vous l'avez
anticipé pas anticiper calculer pas
calculer c'est dans le domaine on la
voit on la voit arriver depuis des
années vous savez moi je
je j'ai toujours travaillé sur ces
enjeux de mondialisation donc depuis
j'ai travaillé vécu en Afrique dans les
au début tout des débuts des années 90
en Asie j'ai participé à la à la
construction du mouvement
altermondialiste en bloquant
l'Organisation Mondiale du Commerce à
Seattle ou en participant à la fondation
du Forum social mondial et puis euh que
ce soit à Greenpeace évidemment on est
sur les enjeux internationaux et au
Parlement européen je continue à suivre
ces questionsl j'ai toujours dit qu'à
partir du moment où on laisserait se
mettre en place une
mondialisation des intérêts économiques
uniquement une mondialisation où ce sont
des acteurs économiques gigantesques qui
prennent la main sur l'ensemble euh de
la régulation de la gouvernance
internationale nous nous nous irions
vers tous les replis identitaires parce
que les gens sont totalement paumés et
ils sont prêts à écouter n'importe qui
qui leur dit le monde c'était tellement
mieux avant tellement mieux avec les
frontières tellement mieux avec machin
moi si je me bats pour l'Europe
aujourd'hui c'est pour que l'Europe soit
un vecteur de régulation publique de la
mondialisation que les souverainetés
démocratiques que les droits humains les
droits sociaux et les droits
environnementaux priment sur les
intérêts du commerce et des
investisseurs donc pas de sortie de
l'Europe avec avec Jad non pas de sortie
pas non parce que comme le dit Bruno
Latour l'Europe aujourd'hui est seule
mais seule l'Europe peut nous sauver
lutter contre les paradis fiscaux lutter
contre la colonisation Google faire de
l'armisation numérique la souveraineté
numérique on fait quoi et ben faut
favoriser l'émergence acteurs européens
du numérique puissant qui nous
permettent aussi d'avoir pour ces
acteurs numériques les valeurs
européennes c'est par exemple toute la
protection des données personnelles où
les vers ont porté à l'échelle
européenne et ont réussi à avoir le
système le plus protecteur en matière de
données personnelles quelles sont les
entreprises pour vous qui protègent les
les données personnelles en Europe et en
France c'est B justement le problème
c'est que il faut en permanence avoir
une régulation extrêmement forte pour
pour être sûr qu'il y a pas une
commercialisation de nos données
personnelles mainant là maintenant
quelles sont les boîtes qui protègent
les données personnelles j'enen j'en
connais pas qui se soit fait une
réputation extraordinaire sur le fait
qu'ils sont exemplaires en matière de
protection des données personnelles
qu'est-ce que vous utilisez comme
navigateur ah moi j'utilise comme tout
le monde je googlise pas mal euh donc
c'est vrai que je suis dans ce système
là et c'est aussi pour ça que je veux
absolument que Google soit soumis euh
aux protection au droits européens en
matière de données personnelles et qui
ne puisse et donc c'est ce qu'on a
obtenu est extrêmement fort c'est-à-dire
que Google même basé aux États-Unis ne
peut pas utiliser des données
personnelles de citoyens européens ne
peut pas les vendre sans leur
consentement ça c'est important Firefox
ça vous parle bien sûr j'ai eu Firefox
notamment Internet Explorer oui mais
tout ça mais après c'est vrai queot de
recherche utilis
Microsoft ou que les autres systèmes
avant d'être sur Mac j'étais sur Firefox
ou Linux ça vous parle bien sûr mais
vous savez on défend le logiciel libre
on défend tout ça mais si vous me dites
dans mon utilisation quotidienne à
travers les outils que j'utilise c'est
vrai que c'est pas c'est pas ce que
j'utilise ça veut pas dire que je me bat
pas pour que ça existe et que ça prenne
le pas comment comment vous pouvez vous
battre pour quelque chose alors que vous
l'utilisez pas vousê ou mais ça
m'empêche pas de faire en sorte que tous
ces systèmes là soi encore une fois
soumis à des
réglementation extrêmement stricte en
matière de protection des données
personnelles faites ce que je dis mais
pas ce que je fais non parce que j'ai
jamais empêcher quiconque mais c'est
pour ça que je veux aussi qu'il y ait
des des opérateurs numériques européens
pour justement on ait le choix vous avez
des pistes dans ce sensl moi je suis pas
pour que l'État construise des
entreprises du comme construit des
entreprises en permanence je veux dire
le plan informatique de la France
englouti des milliards en prétendant
définir des technologies et des méthodes
d'utilisation d'innet il y a une telle
vitalité dans le numérique aujourd'hui
que je crois que la question c'est
d'encadrer du point de vue des libertés
individuelles le développement du
numérique mais surtout de faire en sorte
que le numérique puisse prendre toute la
place à partir du moment où c'est un
outil pour rendre plus horizontal la
société plus participative la société
plus inclusive la société et ben que les
que les que les startup et tout ça nous
invente le monde de demain c'est pas mon
boulot à
moi il nous reste 7 minutes j'ai cru
entendre votre spin doctor rentrer dans
la salle
euh d'ailleurs on tient à vous préciser
qu'on ne donne jamais le plan ni les
questions de nos interviews on vous
remercie quand même ah bah de toute
façon on vous remercie de nous avoir
appelé pour les avoir quand même bah ah
oui c'est normal qu'on sache sur quoi on
va être interrogé vous savez moi je
prétends pas avoir la science infuse sur
absolument tous les sujets mais en même
temps remarquer que je réponds de bonne
volonté à toutes vos questions y compris
quand on passe de la Chine à
l'agriculture biologique et après exprès
d'habitude on fait mettre les mains sous
les cuisses pourquoi c'est vous avez vu
la vie des autres
euh oui bah ça s'appelle un
interrogatoire ah oui ouais mais moi je
je moi je suis un grand dém je suis prêt
à me prêter à toutes vos questions mais
les G g les gens qui me disent dans la
société en général comment je dois me
comporter ça me saoule terriblement
qu'est-ce que vous pensez des référendum
alors tout à l'heure je l'ai dit je
préfère le terme votation citoyenne par
comme Suisse oui parce que le problème
dans notre pays le référendum le
référendum est toujours plébiscitaire
c'est on fait voter les français pour
qu'il donne le pouvoir à
Napoléon de manière éternelle pour
Napoléon et ses descendants donc moi
j'aimerais que les Françaises et les
Français puissent participer s'exprimer
sur des questions de leur quotidien les
questions de leur région ou des
questions plus importantes de en
répondant à la question je veux pas qu'à
chaque fois on soit sur est-ce que les
je sais pas quoi les cours d'école
doivent être vert ou bleu et que à
chaque fois on vote en sachant si on
veut on veut buter ou pas le président
de la République ça je trouve ça
ridicule donc des votations citoyennes
mais aussi un grand référendum européen
sur une nouvelle Constitution mais tous
les Européens votent en même temps le
même jour référendum d'initiative
populaire qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
on se bat pour ça on se bat notamment à
l'échelle européenne pour que ça existe
énormément cette idée que les citoyens
et je l'ai dit tout à l'heure puisse
s'emparer aussi du processus
d'initiative législ législative ça me
paraît extrêmement important mais ça
veut pas dire que les citoyens doivent
en permanence faire le boulot de la
démocratie représentative minutes pour
répondre à notre dernière question
laisser un conseil pour les jeunes
générations une bouteille à la mer sur
Internet c'est la question qu'on pose à
chacun de nos
invités c'est à vous et ben que les
jeunes se prennent en main personne ne
leur donnera jamais le pouvoir moi je
suis responsable politique et sil y a un
discours que souvent je n'aime pas c'est
le discours classique qui est fait à la
jeunesse parce que généralement quand il
y a un discours à la jeunesse c'est pour
leur dénier le droit d'être des adultes
responsables à chaque fois qu'il y a un
discours à la jeunesse c'est de dire on
va organiser votre passage à l'âge
adulte mais l'âge adulte ça sera vers 30
ans quand vous aurez peut-être un CDI
quand vous aurez peut-être votre
logement et que vous serez capable de
vous payer un loyer quand peut-être vous
aurez une vraie mutuelle moi je dis qu'à
16 ans un jeune est un adulte et qu'il a
la le droit de participer pleinement à
la société en votant en ayant une
garantie universelle des loyers en
pouvant toucher comme tout le monde le
RSA ça s'il en a besoin en pouvant se
former que 1 million de jeunes Européens
puissent circuler en Europe et vous
savez quand 1 millions de jeunes
Européens circulent en Europe et ben
quand vous passez un an à l'étranger
dans 25 % des cas vous tombez amoureux
et ben c'est ça aussi la société que je
veux c'est une société du métissage
c'est une société de l'ouverture c'est
une société où les jeunes sont notre
avenir mais les jeunes sont des adultes
comme les autres avec les mêmes droits
les mêmes possibilité d'émancipation bon
bah écoutez merci on n pas eu le temps
de vous poser des questions concernant
le revenu universel le cannabis et tout
un de chos mais bon chez les écol le
cannabis en général ça se passe bien non
on est pour la légalisation c'est un
enjeu de santé de sécurité et puis quand
c'est quand c'est quand c'est récréatif
il y a pas de problème vous avez des
questions à nous poser non tout va bien
j'imagine que vous avez posé à peu près
toutes les questions que vous vouliez
quand même non je vous aurais gardé un
petit peu une heure de plus parce queon
commence à se mettre en jambe là mais je
vois que votre spin doctor nous presse
ben on a d'autres rendez-vous c'est
comme ça bon Yannick jado merci merci de
votre
[Musique]
invitation